[Musique]
charlie watts le batteur des rolling
stones ce mât sa maison en pleine
campagne à seulement 50 km de londres
interviewé par giorgio walsky
qui je suis
j'en sais rien je suis peut être moi
même vraiment ici dans ma maison
n importe où je veux dire que c'était à
tombouctou ce serait moi quand même mais
je pense que je suis
quelque chose qui est différente
c'est
[Musique]
jamais très bien pu m'exprimer dans les
interviews c'est pas du tout mon genre
comprenez
[Musique]
ces deux choses
par exemple on pourrait faire un show je
me considère toujours comme un batteur
et rien d'autre
je finis une tournée en europe il ya
quelques temps est-ce que c'était
fatigant
non pas très fatigant parce que on n'a
pas mis si longtemps à faire la tournée
on travaillait à peu près un jour sur 3
c'était très bien
je sais pas si tu as un succès mais j'en
suis pas si sûr je ne sais pas
what did you du fil
vous avez senti quelque chose de spécial
au sujet du public français ou des
publics en général mais plus
particulièrement public français
soit vraiment je dois les considérer
tous de la même façon huit français
peut-être c'est un peu différent on a
toujours pensé qu'il fallait qu'on se
distingue à paris je sais pas pourquoi
c'était la même chose à londres quand on
a joué là ici mais je n'avais pas eu ce
feeling alive c'était beaucoup mieux
c'était merveilleux
quelle est
[Musique]
la dernière tournée 7 c'est merveilleux
que ça c'est la première fois que j'ai
senti une véritable appréciation des
rolling stones
c'est
la dernière fois qu'on y avait joué on
nous avait accueillis avec des
hurlements et cette fois ci je suis très
conscient qu'on nous écoute est vraiment
je vais pas que nous soyons de jean d'or
qu'est ce qu'on puisse écouter en
restant assis je veux dire je ne joue
jamais consciemment pour des gens qui
sont assis à mes côtés
deux
essais on sait j'étais un peu inquiet
mais ça a été vraiment fantastique
l'annoncé a commencé comme un beau geste
enfin de la façon dont moi joyel tamment
nous devions faire cela gratuitement et
je suis arrivé j'ai vu la foule c'était
une très belle journée le gémeaux
je pensais que ce serait simplement un
nouveau show un concert gratuit comme à
hyde park mais avec plus d'enthousiasmé
notre premier concert depuis longtemps
on était nerveux et puis ça a commencé à
très mal tourner ça finit en catastrophe
avec beaucoup de critiques et de gens
qui écrivent disque mick jagger
représente sorte de démoniaque ou
diabolique qu'est ce que vous en pensez
au
mois de juin au pdg
mais c'est cet aspect parce que je
connais tellement bien
je vois jamais de cette façon là pour
moi vous savez j'aime beaucoup me
like
you fields ou
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez une
once de talent liberté en tant que
musicien
me suis jamais tellement considéré comme
un musicien moi même je suis un musicien
parce que je joue de la batterie mais je
ne considère pas vraiment comme un
musicien
je me suis jamais polariser sur des
trucs essentiellement musique pour la
structure des accords les trucs comme ça
que je devrais faire d'ailleurs mais en
fait je rentre dedans et puis si ça
marche ça marche ce prêt bien et puis si
c'est alors ça vous voyez j'ai toujours
joué comme ça et c'est comme ça que je
gardais web la bastonnade
vous avez des responsabilités vis-à-vis
du public
je crois que nous sommes en quelque
sorte tout responsable mais ça ne change
pas grand-chose paris est fantastique à
ce point
les gens ils se lèvent et ils disent des
choses c'est ce qui me plaît chez eux
je crois qu'ils doivent les dires mais
dire que je suis d'accord que c'est une
autre question je suis probablement
d'accord avec la moitié de ce qu'ils
lisaient pas ce boîtier c'est la même
chose que tout le monde se met donc à
vous dire pas m'inscrire à un parti
politique parce que j'ai pas assez
concerné par sa
boîte
va concerner par une cause politique
j'aime pas la politique je n'aime
vraiment aucun des hommes politiques qui
se manifester parce que quand on y
réfléchit c'est une des choses plus
difficiles entreprendre gouverner les
gens je vous tends pas savoir alors dû
donner en virer tout ce que je veux
faire c'est jouer de la batterie ou
quelque chose comme ça comment dans
l'esprit d'un stage
on a besoin de ses jambes je suis un
sentier qui se tiennent derrière des
êtres qui se disent pas si nombreux
chefs ce type mais je suis là je vis ici
je n'aime pas edward heath je suis
anglais il gouverne de payants ce qu'on
a joué ce que je veux dire et je devrais
vraiment me devais descendre dans la rue
avec une pancarte ou autre chose parce
que je n'aime pas mais je le ferai
jamais c'est peut-être de la paresse
chez pain
[Musique]
c'est dur d'être un artiste mettra
toujours été dur il ya des gens qui sont
morts pour ça d'autres que les oreilles
pour peindre des tableaux
mais ça fait huit mois qu'on travaille à
un 33 tours et peut-être que si je
venais pas si il vous plaira pas ça fait
huit mois y voit un
mois que je suis resté derrière metz le
tube à trier on a tous travaillé comme
des fous milk caisse et en fin de compte
le résultat
d'un
savant fou de faire des disques je crois
que c'est parce qu'on a un esprit très
critique peut-être trop critique je sais
pas c'est très drôle
est parce que notre orchestre a fait
tellement de bruit pas registre man ray
et ça vient de plus en plus difficile
match j'aurais plus tout ce qu'on a fait
est toujours fait comme ça chaque fois
qu'on enregistre entre tour c'est pour
ça après on a besoin de moi je
sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que
la musique ça deviens tu as comme ça
vous savez mais je suppose que celui qui
entraîne les autres que ce soit micoud
caisse ou celui qui décide de la kx et
dirar et puis moi aussi je suis comme ça
mon petit passage qui est la leur si les
pas sur le disque il faut recommencer
518 enregistrements
et nous voyais beaucoup de gens ont
critiqué pour ça
mais pour nous il faut que ce soit
parfait et pour moi aussi je veux que ce
soit parfait ce qui se passe quelque
chose
à part du temps vous fait que répéter ce
que j'avais déjà fait et puis une fois
et un disque où tout y est avec le petit
quelque chose de plus peut-être la
perfection
j'ai pas de grandes idées en ce qui
concerne la direction musicale en fait
j'ai aucune idée de ce qui se passe
c'est pour ça je suis pas bons par
exemple pour aider mikucki ça écrire les
chansons un morceau je sais pas du tout
le faire ce qui arrive ça arrive et si
c'est mauvais je suis désolé je me dis
que je devrais enfin vraiment plus mais
si ça ne l'est pas ce qui arrive ça doit
arriver
[Musique]
quel est votre enregistrement favori
qu'est celui que vous préférez
ce que nous avons fait dernièrement
dernier c'est celui que je peux dire je
sais pas si c'est le meilleur qui avec
le temps qui peut dire ça mais j'aime
bien ce qu'on a fait sur
les gens n'ont pas tort quand ils disent
et c'est de la musique de rolling stone
fait puis en lisent aussi se disent bien
meilleur autrefois je pense pas qu'en
tant que musicien on était meilleurs
autrefois mais peut-être qu'en tant
corcas monétaire aux musiques un peu
plus
primitives c'est difficile chez passion
on peut se rendre compte de ça
maintenant qu'elle aille fais vieux
douchy
est ce que vous considérez comme un
artisan
mais j'ai toujours fait ça parce que
j'ai reçu de manière dont je suis se
travailler
sur scène et jeu je peux dire que je
suis l uqac amateurs de king curtis
j'imagine que
c'est ridicule d'ailleurs parce que je
suis loin d'être aussi bon j'ai pas du
tout la qualité nécessaire pour jouer
avec des joueurs mais j'ai besoin de me
dire que je joue avec lui quand je monte
sur scène je vous en avais imaginé
il a specific en mémoire
s'exhale souvent et surtout quand ça va
bien
tout ce que je fais j'ai l'impression
que c'est c'est déjà du passé je suis
pas très très moderne syriens découverts
mais je suis suffisamment ouvert pour
pour penser à ce qui va se passer
journaux pourra dire si la musique
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est juste que
quelqu'un d'autre a joué qui revient
dans mon jeu je sois tout un tas de
petites choses comme ça
finir charlie watts isku êtes heureux
je crois que je suis les gens pensent
que je ne suis pas mais je crois que
c'est difficile à dire
c'est le mot d'ordre aujourd'hui
soit
6 h sur l'aim femme quand elle a le
cafard ça et souvent femme judy soit
heureuse c'est facile à dire mais mais
que ça ça veut dire en fin de compte ça
veut dire avoir de l'argent être à monte
carlo
j'adore l'argent ce que c'est c'est
formidable et on peut faire un tas de
choses qu'on peut jamais faire sans
argent mais c'est pas vraiment le
bonheur
qu'on peut gagner beaucoup d'argent si
on obtient par exemple un homme à faire
si on aime ça la bourse je pense que
c'était amusant pour beaucoup de gens
j'ai jamais été si connais rien à ce
qu'on appelle l'argent
gagné autant d'argent qu'on le dit
on a dit que me vont gagner un peu
d'argent en europe et sexuellement fou
on a dépensé jusqu'au dernier sou en
europe
ouais c'était le tour d'europe c'était
de carita parce que ça nous prend
tellement longtemps partie en tournée
maintenant
si l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur il ya
ce qui fait le bonheur
le bonheur c'est peut-être de faire les
choses qu'on veut faire ou alors c'est
vraiment la mort
s'est agi au chroniqueur quelque chose
on peut parler indéfiniment par exemple
de faire une table mais au moment où
l'on doit la fabrique et alors là c'est
vraiment le moment décisif où on pense à
la sauce va devenir ou alors c'est
complètement raté je crois que c'est ça
le moment l'instant créateurs pour moi
c'est peut-être ça le bonheur est
mûr et les gens qui crée quelque chose
pour l'équipe qui jouait dans une salle
enfumée
je veux dire gratuitement il le fait
pourquoi ils les fouilleurs un cancer au
poumon il va mourir et et puis encore
quand il aime les gens comme ça
les gens comme sonny rollins
sexuellement de l'anc fait les truc
absolument dingue et pourquoi vous
entendez le disque et et vous vous dites
me voilà pourquoi
j'aime me dire que ça vraiment non
devraient être envoyés
crs racing
[Musique]